38 people have died in Mexico after a
fire swept through a migrant Detention
Center the President says the blaze
broke out when migrants and Asylum
Seekers set fire to mattresses after
discovering that they were being
deported it happened in the northern
city of Juarez near the border with the
United States John Holman reports
the Phalanx of ambulances they came too
late for many
the fire at a migration Detention
Facility and the Mexican border city of
Juarez had already claimed dozens many
of them Guatemalans some Venezuelans
desperate relatives had nothing to do
but mourn or wait for news
you can have a relative die and they
don't tell you he's dead nothing
immediately there were questions chiefly
how did the fire start in his early
morning press conference metzko's
president arrived with answers it was
the migrants themselves he said
this had to do with a protest that they
started when they found out they would
be deported they put mattresses at the
shelter's doors and set fire to them
they didn't think it would cause this
terrible tragedy
protests have happened before in
Mexico's state migration centers those
who've stepped through their doors often
describe them as overcrowded prisons
but this time around there are more
questions how did authorities allow this
to happen to those under their care the
angli a Venezuelan migrant says she was
outside when it happened
I've been waiting for their father since
1pm they told me they were going to hand
him over to me then at 10 pm we started
to see smoke billowing from everywhere
everybody ran away but they left the men
locked in everybody was removed from the
area but they left the men locked in
they never opened the door
ciudad Juarez where the Detention Center
is located has become a pressure cooker
in recent months with large numbers of
migrants and Asylum Seekers staying
there before a push to get to the U.S
shelter heads and activists have accused
authorities of criminalizing them
on Monday night the pressure cooker
boiled over now amid the grief the
inquest will begin
John Holman Al Jazeera Mexico City
Ari Sawyer is a U.S border researcher
for Human Rights Watch she says the
conditions in the migrant detention
facilities are often dire
these deaths and injuries are the direct
results of the turns policies rate
carried out by us and Mexico that focus
on criminalizing migrants and Asylum
Seekers instead of legal processes so
we've documented at Human Rights Watch
The abusive conditions Within These
facilities and we understand that the
migrants were protesting for conditions
there they were protesting a lack of
water it hadn't been given any water and
a leaked video that I've Just Seen shows
that shows appears to show immigration
officials leaving them locked inside of
that cell as the choir plays on so it's
just completely inexcusable also those
doors are they don't have an easy
release there's no electronic release
um that needs a key and and we know that
there are there's physical abuse inside
those detention facilities they're often
overcrowded we understand that that
particular Detention Facility you know
in the Mexican Government right like
says that they're called shelters they
call them shelters but they are just
attention facilities people are locked
up
um and they were overcrowded in that
particular room